this video is made possible by - lane -
Lane is a one-stop shop digital identity
protection tool who go beyond just being
an amazing password manager and provide
identity protection monitoring and
restoration and more visit - link aam
forward slash visual politic and apply
the code visual politic for a 10%
discount the woman you see on the screen
is megwin jowl vice-president of far
away the Canadian police arrested her at
the end of 2018 four years gave a
preview of some of the arguments they'll
be making once her extradition hearing
begins the main reason was because of
alleged violations of America's
sanctions on Iran but there is more to
the story than this the Trump
administration believes China is using
their technology to spy on American
citizens but is this just Donald Trump's
obsession or are there legitimate
reasons to be scared of China China
China China I have to have my China
China China because China China China
China you see whenever we speak about
the military we always talk about air
and sea and land nowadays though we
should add another field technology
ships cameras drones all of these kinds
of innovations have revolutionized
modern warfare
[Music]
as we told you in our previous videos
China is facing an existential threat
and therefore it needs to expand the
military this is why they created what
has been called the string of pearls
strategy this is a set of ports that can
double as military bases that would go
from the South China Sea to Africa and
in another video we told you about what
we like to call sugar-daddy diplomacy
but still there is something important
that China is missing for their military
expansion and that's technology and
catching up with the West in this field
it's not easy and again Xi Jingping
is showing his lateral thinking on this
issue how is he doing that well that is
what we are going to tell you in this
video
[Applause]
[Music]
China the country famous for making
cheap copies of anything that you can
imagine like these copyright violating
weapon bricks with the star Warner's
logo on them is that how you pronounce
it who really knows
[Music]
but make no mistake china's
technological prowess goes way beyond
that in 2015 china's government unveiled
made in china 2025 a ten year plan to
update the state's manufacturing base by
rapidly developing ten high-tech
industries chief among these are
electric cars and other new energy
vehicles next generation information
technology and telecommunications and
last but certainly not least advanced
robotics and artificial intelligence
these sectors are central to the
so-called fourth Industrial Revolution
which is the new buzz word to use when
AI want to look smarter soon there won't
be a single talk show or political
debate that isn't talking about it say
pay attention the fourth Industrial
Revolution refers to the integration of
big data and cloud computing into global
manufacturing supply chains made in
China 2025 is Beijing's plan for
high-tech dominance as big a threat as
the West thinks it is the plan is to
reduce dependence on foreign technology
yeah it is true most of the mobile
phones you can buy are assembled in
China but the majority of the high-tech
components the cameras the high-end
microchips all of that is made in
countries like America Germany or Japan
so far China doesn't have the technology
to produce these components itself and
that's why this desire to become a tech
superpower is part of the so-called
Chinese dream
the Chinese dream is closely linked to
the dreams of people in other countries
China's development is facilitated by
the development of the world and it will
bring about greater impetus and
opportunities for the common progress of
all countries President Xi Jinping
October 22nd 2015 and now China is
trying to make another Silicon Valley
the city of Nanjing for example is
currently developing a research park to
foster China's next generation of tech
giants we're talking about an area as
big as Seattle housing dozens of
high-profile startups and companies and
that's just one big city it's worth
noting that this comes with the support
of the Chinese government and this
support comes with heavy regulations
businesses must meet certain criteria in
order to qualify for tax relief and
other support and there's even more here
besides providing subsidies and setting
targets how does China intend to achieve
its goals by investing or directly
buying American and European startups
Chinese companies both private and state
backed have been encouraged to invest in
foreign companies in order to gain
access to advanced technology in 2016
alone the value of Chinese acquisitions
in the United States amounted to over 45
billion dollars and the same goes for
Europe all right so I can probably guess
what you're now thinking I mean so what
I mean what exactly is the problem if
China wants to invest in other countries
well the problem is that many of those
investments might be a strategy to steal
technology from Europe and America and
I'm really not making this up if you
want an example here it is you probably
know Oreo cookies well that sweet cream
they have in the middle is so pearly
white because they use a special
chemical component it's something based
on titanium dioxide that requires rocket
science in order to produce the pattern
to produce this belongs to a company
called DuPont sands it's a secret about
it as coca-cola is about their formula
so one day a Chinese spy Walter knew he
stole this formula
[Music]
years later at Chinese factory was mass
producing this white tints and this is
just one example of course in the Oreo
case that patent holders good accent
filed a lawsuit against the spies but
what would happen if instead of being a
spy this Walter Luo guy had been the
main shareholder of the Company in this
case he would have had access to the
company's secrets without any problems
and in all you're thinking well who
cares about cookies well cookies you're
right they're not important but what if
instead of white cream we were talking
about military technology then we can
have a bit of a problem and believe me
China will love to get military secrets
from European and American companies and
you might be wondering is this as bad as
some politicians and making it out to be
or is this just another chapter in the
ongoing trade war with China well today
we're going to answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history more money and
even more deals when it comes to
investing in technology Americans
already have a huge funding market on to
create a start up just in California
you're going to find loads of VC firms
competing to make you the best deal the
European Union however is more of virgin
territory and this is why the European
Union became the favorite destination
for Chinese investors according to
several studies published by the market
or Institute for Chinese studies that
foreign direct investments or FDI in the
EU totaled more than 35 billion euros in
2016 with a 77 percent increase from the
previous year and Germany they were the
largest recipient accounting for 31% of
all of that money
Chinese investment in Europe is
increasing the region accounted for a
core of China's FBI outflows in 2017
Chinese investors have always showed a
strong predilection for tech and
advanced manufacturing assets some of
the big deals made where the acquisition
of a German robotics company for 4.4
billion euros and the 6.7 billion Europe
acquisition of the finished gaming firm
supercell and those are just the bigger
ones
just think about what 35 billion euros
can really do in the last couple of
years China again refocusing on the big
three European economies Germany the UK
and France those three together
accounted for 59 percent of their total
investments and look I know right now
I'm throwing a lot of numbers your way
but it's very important in order to
understand the magnitude of this
phenomena one day if you're bored you
can go check out China investment
tracker this is a database launched in
order to track and cover China's global
investment the database tracks China's
global outbound investments since 2005
and it's now hosted by the American
Enterprise Institute the data set is
publicly available and also includes
construction contracts and transactions
that were never completed is buying its
way into Europe bloomberg got to work
and providing us with some pretty
intense numbers just in the past 10
years China has bought or invested in
assets amounting to at least 318 billion
dollars
most of this money went to businesses
but some also went to infrastructure
just in the City of London Chinese
investors purchased a dozen office
towers knowing who is buying all of
these businesses and buildings in Europe
is important in order to try and
understand how this kind of activity
fits into China's foreign policy
giving in mind that the line between
state and private is pretty blurry in
China it's worth noting that at least 63
percent of the total investments come
from state backed companies or
investment funds in other words it is
China's government's that is investing
in technological firm now the question
comes - why is this all about making
money or maybe there's something more
here well that's what we're going to
look into right now
don't touch my tech even though Silicon
Valley it comes to mind whenever someone
talks about tech we shouldn't overlook
European tech giant's Spotify for
example is the most valuable streaming
service on the planet the company has
been valued as around 16 billion dollars
and where to Spotify come from well that
would be Sweden but we're not here to
talk about civil technology we're here
to talk about military technology and
here Arabs got a lot to offer
for example one of the biggest weapon
manufacturers in the world is the Airbus
group the corporation has headquarters
in France and the Netherlands they
design manufacture and sell civil and
military aerospace products worldwide in
2017 had a reported revenue of 67
billion euros military tech is a very
sensitive strategic topic and it's
usually kept very well-hidden but if you
invest in a company you can access their
databases and their secrets at the end
of the day you're one of the owners and
this is exactly what happens to humma
plumbers are these armored cars that you
see on the screen now the American army
has been using them for decades in the
year 2008 the company who manufactured
them the subsidiary of General Motors
was at the edge of collapse and this is
when a Chinese company they came to the
rescue
in their first negotiations they asked
for a couple of years so they could
examine the cars I mean that would be
pretty normal I mean you don't invest
half a billion dollars in a company
without knowing exactly what they do so
how I gave them those cars then the
White House with Obama as president
vetoed the Chinese acquisition why well
they simply didn't want to sell a
military company to another country
nevertheless those Chinese investors
already got and what they want it they
had the cars so well what did they do
with them well they reverse engineered
them they basically took all of the
pieces apart and learned how to build
their own Hummers from scratch since
then these are the Chinese Army's
brand-new armored cars
yep they look almost exactly the same as
the American hummus and this is just one
example there are many many more so in
Europe well they learn the lesson and
there determines not to repeat the same
mistakes
[Music]
is Europe finally pushing back on
Chinese investments and that's why
Europe's three major powers Germany
France and the UK have all recently
taken steps to closely scrutinize
Chinese investments and they have
reasons to be afraid for example Germany
produces some state-of-the-art tanks the
so called lapid's well according to many
experts the new Chinese tanks have
identical motors this is why Germany
recently vetoed the Chinese attempt to
invest two billion dollars in robotics
in their country citing national
security concerns
[Music]
the government is also working on a
proposal that would strengthen
governments all vetting of acquisitions
by foreigners and the same is happening
in France French lawmakers passed
legislation as early as 2003 that also
allows the government to scrutinize and
veto foreign investments since then they
have added more regulations for
companies in the Big Data artificial
intelligence and robotics industries
France is open to long-term investment
from China but not looting French
finance minister Bruno Lima II as you
know anytime France and Germany agree on
something it's just a matter of time
before the European Union follows suit
the agreed package will ensure that the
EU and its member states are equipped to
protect their quote essential interests
while remaining quote one of the most
open investment regimes end quote in the
world and this is where the complicated
part starts because the line that
separates those essential interests and
they're not so special is extremely
blurry you see we can all agree that a
company that manufactures tanks is a
weapon manufacturer and that we want to
protect it there's no debate about that
but what happens with the company that
produces the microchip that controls the
computers on board the tank I mean that
might be a company that works with a lot
of people not just ones with military
interests in fact a bus itself has a
Civil Division and they produce
commercial airliners
question comes around too well should we
protect that as well in other words
those essential interests can become a
Trojan horse for all kinds of
protectionist and arguably financially
xenophobic measures and believe me the
risk on this matter is also very real
Emmanuel macron promises to stop foreign
investors buying up French farms after
China land grab yep you heard that right
how on earth is farming related to the
military it's pretty hard to understand
right but the truth is French farmers
don't like the Chinese a macron well
he's got elections to win in the future
and the same goes for the United Kingdom
for example in the year 2016 the British
government vetoed a Chinese investment
in the nuclear power plant was that a
strategic decision or was it just
straightforward protectionism well it's
pretty hard to tell
[Music]
and I know I know I many of you might be
thinking right now in the Chinese right
well the truth is we need money remember
that story about Hummer well guess what
happened right after the White House
vetoed that Chinese acquisition
General Motors too close Hummer after
sale fails from one day to the next
almost 3,000 people lost their jobs and
what about those 35 billion euros for
European startups on a previous visual
politic video we've told you the story
behind Silicon Valley and how Europe was
able to attract venture capital funds
it's a fact
Brussels Berlin and Paris are going
crazy trying to find on trap and nerves
Europe wants to lead the so-called
fourth Industrial Revolution but you
don't do that with grants and subsidies
alone you need venture capitalists and
private investors of all kinds and a big
share of this money it's coming from
China in fact you remember mom Hong Zhu
the hallway vice-president well don't
forget that just in Europe alone more
than 11,000 people are working for this
company so now the question comes to you
which is more important economic growth
and innovation on national security is
there a way to protect both things at
the same time well please leave your
answer in the comment section below and
while you might not have to personally
deal with national security you do have
to deal with your personal digital
security that's why you probably need
dashlane who will keep your online
identity safe
- Lang will protect you from all sorts
of threats to your identity and there's
a lot of hackers out there in the best
way to keep yourself safe online is with
- name - Lane is a one-stop shop digital
identity protection tool that includes a
VPN for all of your devices so you can
use public internet safely and
anonymously they also do something
called dark web monitoring which
basically means that they monitor the
underbelly over the web for people
selling your data and will alert you if
this is happening so that if a service
you've signed up for like Equifax or
Sony perhaps suffers a data breach -
Lane will tell you right away and alert
you to other services which share that
username and password so you can quickly
change them before hackers get access to
other sites
Plus Nash Lane does what it's always
done it stores your passwords it keeps
your personal data secure it fills all
those annoying boxes for payment info
and passwords for you now a lot of -
Lane is totally free but there are some
premium upgrades you can buy if you want
more from the service to see if those
are right for you you can take a 30 day
free trial and after that get a 10%
discount using our code visual politic
at - Lane comm forward slash Vishal
politic so just go protect yourself now
there's a link in the description box
below as well don't forget to subscribe
to this channel like it as well and as
always I'll see you next time and if you
want to learn more about politics and
here even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider Media we have
a podcast at reconsidered Mediacom slash
podcast see you there